so
um so i'm my full name is kevin davidi
uh you can call me coven easiest way to
remember k with an oven and um
for the last few years i've been making
interactive and public art and more
recently i've been thinking about how to
bring the internet into that so how to
make works for a wider public
and it's really exciting for me to be
here right now because the javascript
community has been a big influence in
the values i have in making this work
especially in like the emphasis of of
building openly and collaboratively
and so i tweeted out some links for some
of the demos and uh later on we'll try
them out maybe they'll work maybe they
won't but either way we'll have some fun
so a little bit about myself
i work at a company called in bedley i'm
coming down from boston and
what we do is it's an api for embedding
media
so
people use it in their apps or websites
to create media mashups or expressive
media stuff open source's tool recently
player.js for working with
movie players or sound players
a few years ago i began a public art
group called new american public art
with a few collaborators and whatever we
make it must follow two principles one
it's interactive so whatever we make
must respond to you and two it's public
if you go to the piece you must be able
to see it or engage with it uh for free
you know you shouldn't have to pay
anything for it and we we did this
because we realized that there's a huge
opportunity in cities and public spaces
for this kind of work to create a
platform for conversation or just to
have fun and meet new people and just
more citizen engagement
i want to tell you about this group the
awesome foundation recently i've been
participating in
and
it's because yesterday a lot of you made
some pretty awesome projects what they
do is there's several chapters all
around the states and once a month many
of them give thousand dollar grants so
if you need some funding for materials
send your project idea to them and then
maybe you'll get funded it's not only
like open tech projects but just you
know various art projects or socially
socially conscious projects or maybe
business prototypes
so on making interactive and
collaborative art
um traditionally like when we think of
traditional art we think about going to
a gallery and seeing a painting and we
take a picture of it but we we draw
meaning from it we could talk about it
with interactive art it's more of a
two-way street so here's a piece by
daniel rosen which i think is really
interesting there's a camera on it and a
whole lattice of motors
and they move
they move these little objects that are
attached there to create what looks like
a silhouette
and we can zoom in a bit further so
here's someone just moving around it
gives you like a little you get a
dialogue with the piece you can explore
it a little bit and when you look closer
it's all these bits of trash moving
around this is really strange
but it's something that's that's a bit
curious you can explore it a little bit
and i think that's interesting uh so we
move to another piece that i find really
interesting is by design io
not only is this interactive
but you could do it with groups of
people
here people are moving around and stuff
and you realize they're controlling
these animations
and i love that that here you have this
space of play and you're you're
you you can go with somebody you know or
somebody you've never met before and all
of a sudden like everything's a bit more
whimsical and silly and fun
i'll do that later um
so that's design io uh
you guys remember that beach ball
what was going on like a couple nights
ago like we could have gone for hours um
that's not an art piece but like i drew
so i just loved it so much hours of
entertainment what was going on
the boundaries of that were really
permeable you could join it you could
leave it like whenever you wanted but
there was a lot of smiling and laughing
and i thought that was really beautiful
um whenever i make a piece that's what i
want to get to somehow
so i'm going to talk about a couple
installations that i've done and then
i'll move more into the internet-based
stuff the first one uh plays with the
metaphor of a dinner table that you can
get a gather around and you know have a
conversation
and lego something that you can use to
build construct together or alone in
this case our dinner table was this
giant beach ball we covered in
fiberglass and magnets and our legos
were little metal pieces
and we took it to a festival and we told
people we've discovered this strange
planet with these strong magnetic
properties and we need their help to
build civilizations
and some people jumped right into it
some people didn't but then you know
soon they wanted to uh but it was cool
to see how this this could become like
like a sandbox this could become a world
to explore um someone brought a godzilla
and put magnets on its feet that could
live on the planet and destroy some of
the buildings uh you would see things
other people made maybe you want to copy
it maybe you'd want to add to it
you could destroy things you could
construct with a friend or meet new
people as you're as you're working on
these pieces um and one of my favorite
things was that like families could get
involved too so here you have three
generations uh the daughter the father
and the grandfather all like playing
with this piece and they're smiling
they're having fun this is cool
uh here's another piece this is a really
simple prototype um
just uh
actually i'll plug this in it's um a
microphone connected to an led strip
and the louder the sounds that it picks
up
the um
yeah there you go
the the more it glows
and so there's many like this is very
flexible you could put it in a club you
could put in a gallery you can attach to
a sculpture
i'm coming from boston it gets really
cold in the winter so we put it outside
maybe it'd make the winter better
and it picks up the ambient sound
and so if you yell
it starts to glow and it's not really
okay to yell in public but this thing's
like you can yell it's totally fine
oh
um so what what is it that that i'm that
i'm seeing that happens okay like people
this brings people together this makes
wherever we install it it makes the
space feel more welcoming and then like
for groups of people participating they
can get more creative and they can get
more playful and i feel like you get you
can build meaning together with this
sort of work so now we're looking at
this medium of the web where there's so
many tools for interact interactivity
and also collaboration
can i can i make those those similar
experiences can i can i bring them into
the web similarly like the only way you
could yell at that led thing is if you
were there like but what if i connected
to the internet so now you could yell at
your computer and then maybe it would
light up
so the browser is a canvas all of these
libraries that are being written they're
being open source i can i can download
and i can use all the apis available i
can use this is a pretty powerful canvas
it's network too i'm making this in
javascript this this you know there was
a reason for this the community is so
strong if i had a question i could find
the answer or i somebody i know would
know where the answer is um the ubiquity
of it i create something for my computer
and it'll work on your computer and i'll
work on other ones if i tweak it a bit
and just the general interest you make
something crazy and like people want to
know what's going on they're interested
in what's possible with these
technologies
so the my first like kind of foray into
this of like public art putting the
internet to it is inspired by a piece by
kusama there's this room with furniture
in it painted completely white and when
you walked in you were given stickers
and you could put a sticker wherever you
wanted and i love to trust the artist
gave in this like yeah you can
you can leave your mark here it's okay
so what would that be like on the web
okay cool like i could draw circles on
this web page then i can add web sockets
so like i could see the circles you draw
sweet cool all right so this is like
this is familiar to us we all we all we
all get this but like for some people it
feels like magic you know and that's
kind of fun and then you get these
interesting patterns like faces and
circle patterns but really once it's on
a screen then you could do a lot of
different things with it you could
project it on a building
and like the scale is suddenly so
different it's not about my hand and my
in my head anymore it's like my hands in
my head it's like my whole body like you
walk in front of this and you feel it
and somebody walks by and rarely do you
see something of this scale in a city
that you can change but now you can you
just go to this website on your phone
you can change it i wasn't even here
this was in grand rapids i was in
summerville i went on the website and i
changed it too and it was wonderful and
it took like screenshots and it was felt
really good um here's another building
we projected on and some of the patterns
you know someone wrote a k
because i made it
and here's a happy face someone started
drawing hair on it
help
i don't know why someone was
desiring help through this there's other
channels um
like different patterns like that a
happy phase um so we can try it if you
want to
um
so like
if you whoa
yay okay cool so what's happening this
is all of us doing this together
and it's working
great you're in my talk with me
maybe i'll return oh my god this is so
many yay okay so i'm gonna leave that
open
okay so now screens now objects um this
is a sweet led piece by leo villareal
and you go through it and there's all
this beautiful shimmering i want to be
able to change that in some way so
got an led grid hooked it up to the
browser
um node serial and all right now i'm
drawing on it okay once it's working in
the browser cool okay i built a housing
so now i can take it on the airplane it
doesn't look as sketchy
and then i could draw on it with a phone
like now it's with a phone okay now one
phone can draw with it then i can get
multiple phones sweet now we have a
collaborative like piece of art that we
can all access with our phones and you
can imagine this in a storefront and
like that storefront that area suddenly
becomes so much more activated and this
is just a small prototype there's like
many other possibilities i'm going to
return to this kind of stuff later on in
the talk now i'm going to go to other
weird internet art stuff
tumblr as a medium for art gifts are
popular on tumblr i was making some gifs
and posting them many of them didn't
work out but some of them did and that
like triggers these neural
synapses and you just want to make more
but i didn't have time to make so many
more like it takes a while to make one
that's compelling so i just set up a
script to make them these like really
minimal gradients because i found them
very soothing and i'd post them every
three hours i was generating them with
the canvas and then using phantom to
auto post them or to auto generate them
and then i'd post that um then i wake up
one morning and it's like whoa
just got a lot of followers this is
doing way better than i am what does
this mean about me on tumblr
and you see these numbers they make you
feel great but then you look at it a
little bit further and then i saw
comments on one of the reblogs if you're
like me and often feel overstimulated by
visual stimuli i recommend this blog
like the blog i put with all those
graphics
basically it's just really nice and i
read this and i was like wow that's
really kind of you to say
and i'm also really glad that i made
your day a little bit better
we're both really happy right now
and i don't know you and you don't know
me but you know things are going to be
okay
so this uses p5 it's uh rewriting
processing in javascript i highly
recommend to check it out if you want to
get into creative coding it's amazing uh
canvas and phantom of course um all
right so now we have this webcam we take
selfies with it all right what can i do
with that i was looking at pixel sorting
yesterday we learned a little bit about
sorting so i was looking at pixel
sorting and uh like glitch art so i was
like what if i pixel sorted my face and
there's my face boom pixel sorting
okay so it's like abstracted i don't
know i started thinking really deeply
about it i was like all right this is
the end of 2013 when i made this it was
the year of the selfie but 2013's over
welcome to another youtube like take
your photo and obliterate it boom cool
art and uh here's here's like what the
app looked like and you get this gif of
your face and so people like started
taking like i put it out online people
shared it and then so just like random
people started sending me their faces
getting obliterated and um
it was like younger folks older folks
but then also like i like this one
because it was like with the cat so it
was like cat selfie obliteration
and then here was another artist who
liked to do visual effects in the
browser
forest and so he saw what i had made and
then he made this and sent it to me and
then we met each other and it was cool
like or we met each other online and
that's always fun to like make and then
dialogue through that um so that used
canvas uh
getusermedia for the image webworkers to
make the pixel sorting faster and like
the best pixel sword library um
so forrest and i like later on work
together on this other piece
this javascript facial tracking library
came out what so we were like let's use
that um and we just added these crazy
visuals on it like circles and things
like that it made no sense but it was
really stimulating and we added like
little screenshots in the background
and we just put it up for for art hack
day
and it was fun like what's more fun than
the piece it's really something what's
more fun is seeing how people responded
to it
it was like when they would they would
try to get the algorithm to recognize
them and then once they were recognized
it's like boom they were the chosen one
and then they'd start making faces at it
and then like they would just forget
about everyone else and then their
friends would like kind of nudge them
and try to be the chosen one and this is
like the best metric of success like
someone took a selfie with it i was like
yes
so that's like get user media
clm tracker is the facial recognition
tool
canvas
all right beyond the web camera
using the kinect
uh is it possible to stream buffers
visual buffers to
the browser
i tried it with socket i o things got
really slow i didn't know what i was
doing
i was recommended to use websocket
streams and then it worked and here's
just the visual buffer
and then the next question was can you
do
simple computer vision stuff in in the
browser can you do smoothing
so here's smoothing over over space but
then also between frames over time and
it was working and things weren't
slowing down too much wow cool
next edge detection can i do can i do
edge detection yes it is possible
this piece was like less about art and
more about is it possible uh and so it
was working and then we
i put it up at the show and like this is
i kind of see as v1 but like you can you
can imagine like you can hook up videos
to this you could put sounds to it
anything that's available in the browser
you can now use to use with this sort of
thing
but like you could get edge detection
live edge detection in the browser cool
so that was with node connect and
websocket streams and again just canvas
i learned about more about canvas
earlier so i can even i can make this
even more efficient um
i like to play music so
definitely i'd mess around with web
audio toys um it's fun to do like little
little projects
so when i got a leap like clearly i
would make a theremin like everyone else
did
so this is a
can we get along here
oh thanks
um so that's that's this one
and here's like adding some filtering
and this this is fun like maybe a little
stressful
but like it was hard to really share
this so so i was saying okay what else
can you do okay minimal minimal graphics
minimal graphics in the browser with
sounds cool
okay now it's going to be i swear the
next one is a lot happier sounding
but for some reason i was using d3 for
this you don't use d3 for this kind of
application i don't know why i did it's
like learning and stuff
so that was a stressful one here's one
that's more relaxing
it's a nice moment we're sharing
so like you know i can share that and
see what happened but really like none
of this stuff really really compelled me
until
this came out this came out recently
like a month ago it like went viral and
it was like the wow
oh cool
it's growing
um this came out and
and it was amazing you press a key and
sounds happen and visuals happen and
then you could just play beats
um but the real thing the the real
compelling part about it is that it
would also work on mobile on the mobile
browser
and before one when you wanted to do
stuff that was really low latency you'd
have to go native but now you don't have
to now there's a whole new set of
possibilities for for mobile synth apps
and and quick gestures that you could
start exploring and this this was
incredible because like now i could
share it and people can play with it and
it's even more engaging than you know
just on on this
um so like
you know simple simple one-off
experiments like arpeggiator stuff
um or taking like previous apps that i
made like this one has um
your mouse position becomes like
the input for a synthesizer and uh why
did i stop okay that's done uh
and it's it's like really minimal but um
right now but um basically like on one
side
and like play sounds
okay let's all go
okay um
so there's something that would happen
with this where like when people started
synchronizing with each other it started
to get like
you start to see that behind this dot in
this simple sound there's a person
and and that was really amazing like
like
when when two people start to
synchronize you um
you start to form a language between
each other and this this taught me
something new that you can create these
minimal spaces of expression but really
start to connect with somebody else and
it wasn't just me that felt it like i
went on twitter to see people talking
about it and someone wrote i just
harmonized with somebody but i don't
know who is that weird
and
someone else responded it's natural and
beautiful i was like oh wow cool this is
you feel this and so i'm imagining like
all these different little playgrounds
that are very very minimal very simple
you don't even use you know you're not
using words but where you can connect
with people in a very deep and kind of
intimate way
oh yeah we did the demo and maybe we
could do it again later okay um so
that's socket io web audio api um i'm
going to end with something i've been
working on most recently
and it was kind of taken this idea of
open web art more seriously and being
very open about the process and just
sharing about the process
and the idea was that you'd have some
sort of projection and you'd have your
phones and then when you moved them
around something would happen there uh
it was very broad um i didn't really
know what it would look like but i knew
that i didn't want like this tapping i
wanted like moving so it would be more
about your body and not about looking at
a screen um and so this first test was
just gestures to sound and it's like
totally hacky looking thing um
and that was like that's like the best
ice breaker ever like people ask me what
do i do and i'm like this is what i do
and i posted on facebook sounding all
serious like
try it out and
a few minutes later i get a response
holy crap i just annoyed the entire room
for 10 minutes of bliss
omg just hold it on and run around away
from people chasing you lol
cool so maybe there's something about
this but that was possible because like
they didn't have to download an app i
just shared this website and that
browser supports web audio and the
accelerometer and they can just use it
right away and then share it with their
friends and i love that
oh here's that video from before okay
now it stopped okay um
so oh yeah uh so then over the next few
all right
you know someone showed me a vine of it
on their laptop instead of their phone
cool didn't expect that you just shake
your laptop
and then because it looked so bad i
think people like hacked on it made it
their own built a better ui and made it
collaborative and i love that i loved
like that it was comfortable to add to
it um but then i worked on it made the
sound a bit prettier and uh and added
some visual component
so like you shake it and then there's
like these bursts um and we should play
with oh here's another video of like
take it to a show and then shake it
around um
and then like
one of the people on the show was so
pumped about it like i go to shows and i
just want to be a part of it now i can
be more a part of it and i like that he
felt that way
so we could try this out if you want to
so turn up your sound and uh go to this
website
i don't know what's going to happen like
i'm really amazed that that other sound
thing worked that was cool it got a
little crazy though
oh that's awesome this is getting
beautiful all right
um
so now we're on this page and this is
gonna like
oh man i should have loaded this earlier
so
you have a color on your phone right now
and that's the color
of like the screen of like whatever this
burst is and it's hard to see where you
are right now but i think i'm the green
one i don't know
anyway that's all of us
doing this thing together
and making these cool sounds with our
phones
cool oh well this is still going up whoa
who did this who was this
who was oh my god someone did this
that's so cool you rock you're the best
um
sweet
wow i've never had so many people on it
that's fun that's fun i think i'll make
it brighter or something i gotta you
gotta you gotta test for scale like this
so but that's cool
you don't have to stop i i kind of like
this in the background so that's um this
uses a bunch of things uh web audio um
the the accelerometer of course and then
sparks is on top of three and it's a
particle system library really fun to
play with okay
so
we all
can send each other messages and get to
know each other on the internet like
it's a medium and just in the same way
as before i was like curious of all
right we have public space we have
public art how can this be a means to to
know each other in really beautiful ways
this can happen on the web as well and
and we've seen it so many times and
that's kind of like what i'm interested
in exploring more
i realized why i'm so passionate about
this at an earlier talk in the
conference there was a line that really
resonated with me it was in it was in
jen's talk create a space for people to
feel safe to be people and i want us to
think about this again because it's
really beautiful when we were all
hitting this ball in the air and
laughing and being weird like we felt
okay and it felt okay to be weird and i
think when when you feel okay being
silly and playful you feel safer just
being who you are
and so like with this work all right how
do you do that in public spaces how do
you do that bringing internet to public
space how do you just do it on the web
and when you start when you start seeing
things that work
it gives us new channels to get to know
each other
friends who you've known forever like or
or new strangers um it gives you new
ways to be expressive and playful with
each other and and most of all what's
important to me is it gives you like new
ways to find joy new ways to find
happiness new ways to laugh and smile
together and for me
it's that's one of the most exciting
pursuits in exploring new technologies
and that's what i'm i'm looking to do
with with javascript and networked apps
and in the browser as a canvas
thanks um
and i you know obviously couldn't do it
alone so these are some some of the
collaborators for this work i'm gonna
post these slides online you should
definitely check out their their art as
well um but i'd love to to talk about
ideas and possibilities i've learned so
much about building more openly um this
conference and i want to learn more and
um so let's let's talk let's hang out
later on tonight thanks so much okay
sorry that's two rounds of plus you have
to do the other one okay
you